CHRIS SADEN: Do you have
the next great idea,
but don't know how to build it?
Check out the
Product Design course
developed by Google
and Udacity to learn
the basics of developing your
idea into a marketable product.
Design your first
product faster than you
might think without fancy
tools and thousands of dollars.
In this course, you'll design,
prototype, and test your ideas.
You will also design mock-ups
to communicate your idea
and capture metrics to
support your growth.
This course uses the
methodology that Google Venture
uses with their start-ups to get
them moving quickly and easily.
Start creating today.
For more information,
visit udacity.com/google.